die hinweise auf außerirdisches leben
werden immer drücken da ein experiment
eines wiener forschungsteams legt jetzt
nach
das unter dem minus 200 grad celsius
kalten oberfläche von enceladus dem
saturnmond leben existieren könnte
die fachleute hatten die bedingungen auf
dem saturnmond in aufwändigen
laborexperimenten simuliert dabei
entpuppte sich ein japanischer einzeller
als wahre überlebenskünstler
doch es gibt eine riesige gefahr krieg
zum science fiction jetzt täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
lebensfeindliche als die umgebung auf
dem saturnmond enceladus kann es auf den
ersten blick nirgendwo sein denn seine
oberfläche ist eis bedeckt und es
herrschen temperaturen von minus 200
grad celsius doch mit hilfe der
nasa-sonde cassini hatten
forschungsteams herausfinden können dass
sich unter der dicken eisschicht ein
kilometer tiefer ozean befindet der
grund dafür sind wahrscheinlich gezeiten
effekte des saturns zudem treten aus
rissen in der nähe des enceladus südpols
tausende kilometer hohe damm von themen
heraus und diese enthalten
tatsächlich alle wichtigen zutaten für
leben stickstoffverbindung wie methan
etr anbietern und pendlern und salze
aber auch wasser sauerstoff und
kohlenstoff forschende gehen deshalb
davon aus dass es auf dem meeresgrund
von enceladus heiße quellen gibt mit
temperaturen von bis zu 100 grad celsius
orte an denen es auch hier auf der erde
vor leben nur so wimmelt vor allem
methan gilt als wichtiger hinweis darauf
dass auf dem saturnmond enceladus leben
existieren könnte denn dieses spuren das
entsteht hauptsächlich bei biologischen
prozessen unter luftabschluss die auf
mikroorganismen zurückzuführen sind
somit gilt methan schon seit langer zeit
als biomarker bei der suche nach leben
in unserem sonnensystem ein aktuelles
experiment eines wiener forschungsteams
zeigt jetzt das mikro pls leben wie wir
es von unserer erde erkennen auch auf
enceladus möglich sein könnte dazu
nutzen die fachleute mikroorganismen aus
der gruppe b share die extreme
bedingungen wie hohe temperaturen und
druck aushalten
diese mikroben mit der bezeichnung mit
tarnow thermo kokus ok avensis kommen
vor allem in der okinawa senke vor die
sich fast 1000 meter unter dem
meeresspiegel befindet dann eigentlich
lebensfeindlicher ort zudem
verstoffwechseln diese mikroorganismen
die in der fachsprache auch methan og ne
genannt werden wasserstoff und
kohlendioxid konkret nutzen sie
molekularen wasserstoff h2 als
energiequelle und kohlendioxid co2 als
kohlenstoff und energie quelle um methan
ch4 zu metabolisiert also um daraus ihre
energie zu gewinnen dazu der
biotechnologe simon wittmann der an der
studie beteiligt war insbesondere ein
stamm aus der japanischen tiefsee der an
sehr hohe temperaturen und hohem druck
angepasst ist war besonders geeignet in
ihrem experiment bauten die fachleute
also die möglichen bedingungen des
saturnmondes enceladus nach und
analysierten dann vereinfacht gesagt wie
hoch die methan produktivität der
methanol gene war
in den experimenten zeigte sich schnell
dass diese mikroorganismen unter den
bedingungen dient der saturn und bietet
sogar vermehrungsfähige sind die
experimente wurden sehr aufwändig
gestaltet und so wurden auch die
astronomische geologischen und die
chemisch physikalischen bedingungen die
vermutlich unter dem eis mantel des atom
bundes herrschen simuliert und das
ergebnis ist eindeutig simon wittmann
fasst das so zusammen wir haben gezeigt
dass methan o gene unter enceladus
ähnlichen bedingungen vermehrungsfähige
sind und ein teil des ihnen wasser
eisfontänen nachgewiesenen ch4 daher
prinzipiell biologischen ursprungs sein
könnte wow
selbst bei einem druck von 50 bar waren
die japanischen tiefsee mikroben noch in
der lage sich zu vermehren
bei einem noch höheren druck allerdings
nahm ihre aktivität ab das im labor
simulierte enceladus mehr zeigte aber
auch dass sich auch noch weitere sehr
vermehren konnten das forschungsthema
wien schließt daraus dass eis monde wie
enceladus oder der jupitermond europa
der ebenfalls einen unterirdischen ozean
besitzt gute aussichten bieten
außerirdisches leben zu entdecken
vielleicht sogar noch bessere als der
mars auf dem ja derzeit nach
methanquellen gesucht wird klar ist
dabei aber auch zu berücksichtigen dass
die bedingungen die nun im land
nachgestellt wurden nicht unbedingt 11
denen des unterirdischen wasser ozeans
auf enceladus entsprechen
trotz des riesigen aufwands bestimmte
bio signaturen wie beispielsweise lipide
oder bestimmte isotopenverhältnisse
könnten langfristig gesehen aber dabei
helfen
methan bilden das leben auf dem
enceladus aufzuspüren und diese
vermutung ein für allemal zu belegen
doch die aktuelle studie aus wien macht
auch noch eine andere sache deutlich und
das ist eine große gefahr
raumsonden von der erde stellen
möglicherweise eben eine große gefahr
dar denn sie könnten 1 monde wie
enceladus im schlimmsten fall mit
irdischen organismen kontaminieren weil
diese eben unter den extrembedingungen
überleben könnten und noch eine andere
frage ist super spannend bestehen aliens
aus fleisch und blut hier geht für
diesen video unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und unbedingt neugier zone
wissenschaft gewissenhaft abonnieren ich
zähle auf euch
bis dann bleibt dran